>> ♪ ♪
>> Sean: JOINING US NOW AUTHOR
OF TRUMP VERSUS CHINA, FORMER
HOUSE SPEAKER AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR NEWT GINGRICH.
TO BE A DEMOCRAT, YOU HAVE TO
REJECT ALL OF THE FAIRNESS YOU
PROVIDED THE MINORITY PARTY.
AND BILL CLINTON AND HIS
ATTORNEYS.
TO BE A DEMOCRAT YOU HAVE TO
CARE ABOUT FOREIGN ELECTION
INTERFERENCE WITH RUSSIA BUT NOT
THE DIRTY DOSSIER.
TO BE A DEMOCRAT YOU HAVE TO
IGNORE THE BIDEN'S QUID PRO QUO
AND HUNTER BIDEN PAID MILLIONS.
IF YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT YOU HAVE
TO BELIEVE ANYBODY THAT MADE AN
ACCUSATION AGAINST KAVANAUGH BUT
IGNORE THE ALLEGATIONS AGAINST
THE GOVERNOR OF THE COMMONWEALTH
OF VIRGINIA.
THERE IS NOTHING I SEE THE
PRESIDENT DID ANYTHING WRONG.
I ARGUE HE FAITHFULLY EXECUTED
THE LAWS OF THIS COUNTRY.
>> THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT THE
AGREEMENT MADE BETWEEN PRESIDENT
CLINTON AND UKRAINE REQUIRES THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
TO COOPERATE IN CORRUPTION
FIGHTING IN THE UKRAINE.
TRUMP WAS DOING EXACTLY WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD BE GOING.
REMEMBER, NONE OF THIS IS REAL.
WHAT YOU ARE FACED WITH IS A
DEMOCRATIC PARTY DESPERATELY
COMMITTED TO DESTROYING THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY DON'T CARE WHAT THE FACTS
ARE.
THEY HAVE AN ABSOLUTE DEEP
PASSIONATE NEED, I WOULD ARGUE A
PATHOLOGICAL NEED TO DESTROY THE
PRESIDENT EVEN IF IF THE PROCESS
THEY CRIPPLE THEMSELVES.
ALL OF US WHO ARE TRYING TO TALK
ABOUT FACTS MISUNDERSTOOD THE
CONVERSATION.
THIS IS A DRAMA IN WHICH SCHIFF
AND PELOSI AND OTHERS ARE LIVING
OUT THEIR FANTASIES OUT OF
DESPERATION.
I THINK DEEP DOWN THEY THINK
TRUMP WILL GET REELECTED.
THEY ARE FACED WITH A NIGHTMARE.
NONE OF THIS IS REAL.
PEOPLE SHOULD NOT JUDGE IT AS
REAL.
IT'S A THEATER OF HATE TRUMP LED
BY SCHIFF AND PELOSI.
>> Sean: DO YOU BELIEVE THEY
WILL IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT?
IF THEY DO, WHAT SHOULD THE
SENATE DO.
>> WELL, I KEEP WATCHING.
I DO THINK THE REPUBLICANS HAVE
BEEN EFFECTIVE IN ASKING THE
QUESTION:
DID YOU SEE A CRIME?
NO.
DID YOU SEE AN IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSE?
NO.
THE WEIGHT OF THAT I SUSPECT
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF MARGINAL
DEMOCRATS IN DISTRICTS THAT
TRUMP CARRIED WOULD LOVE FOR
THIS TO ALL GO AWAY.
THEY KNOW IF THE VOTE COMES UP,
THEY WILL HAVE TO VOTE YES OR
THEY WILL BE DEVOURED.
IF THEY VOTE YES, THEY WILL
DEVOURED BY THE PRO-TRUMP BASE
OF THEIR DISTRICT.
THEY FOR A VERY, VERY DIFFICULT
SITUATION.
I THINK THAT McCONNELL REACHED A
DECISION.
THEY WILL HAVE A TRIAL.
AS YOU JUST ANNOUNCED EARLIER
WITH LINDSEY GRAHAM BECOMEING TO
CALL IN THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
WITH OTHER THINGS STARTING TO
DEVELOP, I DON'T KNOW IF I WERE
A DEMOCRAT THEY WOULD BE HAPPY
WITH THE KIND OF OPEN HEARINGS
AND THE KIND OF SUBPOENAS THAT
LINDSEY GRAHAM IS LIKELY TO
HAVE.
THEN THE HONEST DEBATE ON THE
FLOOROF THE SENATE WHICH WILL BE
TO THE DISADVANTAGE OF JOE BIDEN
AND THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> Sean: WHAT IS THE EXACT
ASSUMING HE GETS ACQUITED IN THE
SENATE IN SHORT ORDER.
NO HEARSAY ALLOWED.
WE HAVE THE TRANSCRIPT.
NOBODY THEY KNOW SEES ANYTHING
WRONG WITH THE TRANSCRIPT.
I DON'T THINK YOU DO EITHER.
WHAT IMPACT DOES ALL OF THEIR
ACTIONS FOR THE LAST THREE YEARS
AND WHAT WE WILL DISCOVER ABOUT
ABUSE OF POWER TO TAKE DOWN AN
ELECTED PRESIDENT, WHAT IMPACT
WILL THIS HAVE IN NOVEMBER OF
2020 IN 351 DAYS?
>> THE BIGGEST IMPACT MAY BE THE
DESTRUCTION OF THE AMERICA NEWS
MEDIA.
OVER 50% OF THE COUNTRY SEES THE
NEWS MEDIA AS ANTI-TRUMP AND
HAVING NO INTEREST IN THE FACT.
THE NEWS MEDIA TODAY IS WEAKER
THAN ANY TIME IN MY LIFETIME.
THAT'S A HUGE DISADVANTAGE FOR
THE DEMOCRATS BECAUSE THE
DEMOCRATS ARE IN POSITION WHERE
THEY NEED THE NEWS MEDIA TO BE
BELIEVABLE.
THEY ARE NOT BELIEVABLE BECAUSE
THE FACT IS EVERY DAY YOU SEE
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" AND THE
"WASHINGTON POST" AND MSNBC AND